we gotta talk about the news you can use
man this is really gonna affect you guys
fauci
he wants to uh uh he has no parties no
parties you can't do new year's eve
parties i'll tell you what i'm having a
new year's eve party yes well we're
we're gonna we're gonna fry up some
steak we're gonna have some trump
champagne and then we're gonna go hit
the casino because they're doing a big
countdown and they got the new barstool
sports thing i think is officially open
oh sweet awesome it looks so amazing
they got wings and beer is gonna be so
much fun
but airbnb
vows to crack down on new year's eve
parties quote as we build upon the party
ban and continue to protect our
community during this unprecedented time
certain holidays such as new year's eve
attract higher risks of unauthorized or
disruptive parties that's why we're
introducing new products and policies to
crack down on disruptive new year's eve
parties helping to protect our hosts and
minimizing neighborhood disruption the
short-term vacation rental platform
announced in a press release on tuesday
the anchor of uh of this plan is a ban
on one night nye bookings and entire
home listings for guests with a history
of positive reviews all right well
airbnb
no parties here here's the initial
parties there's verbo go somewhere else
you know we have verbo it's a great
little process here if you don't like
what airbnb is doing so is this all in
the name of covet or is just this just
to avoid messing up neighborhoods i
think it's it's to avoid messing up
people's homes because when you have
parties at people's homes i mean you
obviously destroy the property that that
people rent and this could be the major
factor in there because you know if i'm
renting a property to someone it's for
them to use it like a hotel not like a
club yeah so covid i think could be the
scapegoat because as someone who's
looking into some some property in vegas
for example
um yeah i'd want to stay away from i'd
actually block that night out so i think
it's a way for them to protect their
properties if i look at it this way i
think cove is just the scapegoat as it
is with every customer service issue
i've ever had since 2020. hey man um i
got this shirt and it's missing two
buttons well you know kovid
how the hell is that covet you know it's
at the end of the day everything man i
think it could be a scapegoat we we got
a super chat from someone you know i see
it in passing where they mentioned as an
as a flight attendant
they're they were saying most people you
know don't have kovid but they're
reporting the reason all the flights are
getting shut down and canceled is
because people are calling in sick with
kovid due to the surge sounds like at
least from this one employee in there in
their bubble it's people just calling
out using covet as an excuse they said
when we claim we're sick with covet we
don't get in trouble
really there's a there's a meme going
around showing a test and someone
drawing in the lines saying this is how
i make sure i don't work on new year's
eve um and there might be some of that
there might be
people faking their tests they're just
saying hey i'm sick here because they
don't feel like working as of course
that's been the overall trend for this
year a lot of people saying i just don't
want to work i don't want to work for a
company and and make dollars that are
going to be absolutely worthless as
their value keeps declining almost every
single day i i see all these photos and
videos of democrats for the most part
not wearing masks now look there are
republicans who don't wear masks too but
they're the ones who come out ragging on
masks and mask mandates so i'm like okay
well that's in line with what they've
been saying when you see these democrats
come out like whitmer like newsom like
pelosi like even faucet that baseball
game where his mask turned down
and i'm like these are these are the
ones who are coming out claiming we need
this how much you want about they didn't
get vaccinated either you know a joke i
i think that might be
it's weird because that's like me you
know doing my whole health and fitness
ifbb pro thing and coming out and then
having that remember that video of
arnold like like topless and it was
really a mess it's like oh my god what
happened arnold it's a hypocrisy like
before before the show mark was eating a
big thing of nacho cheese yeah
by the way i would like to say i've gone
an hour without saying a curse word um
oh yeah you spent time with me today you
know you got it all out earlier well
don't worry in the members only segment
you'll just erupt and wait till you see
my fans only page litany of curses hey
you got to make money man so
i got to make up for the kroger thing so
i'm doing an only fans paige
so
what are we talking about we're talking
about that we were talking about airbnb
cracking down and i said i think
democrats are faking they're lying about
getting vaccinated i absolutely think
there's a lot of people not getting it
who say they are getting it i know
personally people who have doctor
friends who give the injection to an
imaginary spot next to their shoulder i
know multiple people doing that look
when you start mandating things you get
people faking things when they don't
want it you get counterfeits and these
are real cards they're just not getting
the needle in the arm i just think if
there are democrats who are gonna go on
tv and be like everyone's gotta wear a
mask and then they don't it's horrible i
also think the same kind of people are
gonna be like everyone's to get
vaccinated and then don't you know well
ethics and hypocrisy you can't
once you cross
a certain ethical line
you've crossed that line so it becomes
your norm so that's why you have to have
those those lines you don't cross so
once you start lying about one thing i
tell this to my kids all the time if
you're lying about mask you're doing
something else then you can make well i
can do this against this too yeah i can
do this about this too and that's why
i'm always one of those practice what
you preach if you don't believe it don't
say it kind of guys unfortunately
politicians are not the cream of the
crop you know the cream of the crop is
us we're in the private sector we're
building businesses we're employing
people and we probably have higher than
average iqs the people in
washington dc in politics they're
complete morons have you ever talked to
these people they're dumb have you seen
there's a there's a dc-ist put out a
tweet i don't know if you guys saw it oh
yeah and it said this is what dc will
look like if global warming stays on
this path and it showed dc flooded and
my response was i'm not sure if this is
pro global warming or anti-global
warming
yeah just
but i'll leave it there these people
aren't that's why i'm like when i see
these kids while they're
pelosi and bi narcans i'm like dude
these people are dumb like they're not
the smartest people if you've ever seen
the movie um by chris bell bigger
stronger faster they literally there was
a guy i think is waxman who was a
senator or a congressman in california
who voted for the steroid act whatever
to to make him illegal and they when
they asked him what steroids were or
something and he had no clue what he
voted for let's talk second amendment
look into that okay and so these people
there are people who read into it like
mt marjorie taylor green she she
believes what she's saying and she's
well educated and versed on what she's
doing thomas massey that's the guy right
there rand paul as well these are smart
people but you look at a lot of these
people like they don't even show up for
votes they had that one mtg called them
out marger taylor green called him out
where my own senator from uh tennessee
didn't show up to a vote on justice as i
believe it was and it was horrible and
i'm like oh nobody from tennessee is
gonna be on that list then there was a
senator that i really really like who
knows showed up your job is to vote
you don't even work that much yeah go
vote
how many months are they in session it's
like they're out most of the year and
then they show up for a little bit it's
disgusting it's disgusting the way this
has gone and and we just have a bunch of
weak people who are funded by a bunch of
really rich people making the laws and
people like us like i was explaining
earlier i'm not going to run for office
i can't handle that yeah because i'll be
punching people on the floor and i will
never make it past a cam an election
campaign i won't make it i'm not built
for that instead i'm gonna affect the
local level i'm gonna coach kids but the
smart people are out there like elon
musk you don't think that man can run a
country like he's sending people to
space
and he's building generators like okay i
think you need decentralized power
i'm not i'm not i think iron musk can
send people to space i think you can
make an electric car but i don't know
about telling people like you know
effective policies he's also working
better
yeah no he could i mean look man my
eight-year-old son can do better than
these idiots in office right now well
it's because they're self-interested yes
you know if you if you you could take
you know uh some local custodian
as long as he's interested in doing the
right thing for his neighbors in the
country he would do an infinitely better
job than any one of these politicians
absolutely correct you've got you got a
small handful out of you know the
hundreds of members of congress a small
handful you're like rand paul thomas
massey that like people who actually
believe what they're doing and and look
into these things and actually stand up
most of them it's really funny when i'm
reading about members of congress and
i'm like i have no idea who that is it's
like oh someone's being criticized for
not doing their job like who are these
people how are they even on any party
they don't do anything sociopaths
there's a reason the the most amount of
social sociopaths per capita or in
washington dc and i want to go back to
your original kind of point here talking
about how 25 percent of the cases are
from new york as according to the latest
google statistics from yesterday there
was 54 828
cases uh coming from the state of uh new
york specifically in new york city
nationally there was 189
714 cases so that's about 25
coming from new york city specifically
themselves according to the statistics
provided by google nice um so i i
believe if it was florida it would have
been a totally different story if 25 of
the cases came from florida the media
would have been talking about it
obsessively but of course um they're not
but again a lot of these people who are
calling the shots or working with the
politicians or working with the
corporate media and to me there's
there's more about pushing an agenda
pushing a narrative than the truth and
these people are not here to serve you
and and that's why it's it's very easy
to say that there anyone could do a
better job than they will be because
it's obviously true because when you
have someone who is there serving the
special interests they're of course
they're doing everything not into to
your advantage so what they're doing is
deliberately trying to screw you over
and they are i love how pelosi was like
we should be allowed to trade stocks
you know you just asked about it yeah
yeah they were like we should we should
not we should you should block members
of congress from you know buying and
trading stocks like no we're private
individuals we can do this and it's like
oh okay so it's like not a private
individual so they public servants they
know there's a vote coming up the
lobbyists come to them and say hey if
this bill passes bad things will happen
to this company and she goes you know
and then these politicians can be like
i'm going to short this company and then
vote yes
and then they make tons of money because
they are in control of it is corruption
it's how are these people so rich like
biden's worth tens of millions of
dollars it's not from speaking
engagements
like how that's the question you need to
look at like gee i wonder you need to
look at these people and they've been in
like he's been an off like i'm 40 life
his whole life 47 48 years um bernie
sanders didn't really have a job until
he was in his 40s he was my age when he
finally got a job one job
government oh yeah i'm pretty sure
bernie never had a job
so so look at it this way
they're getting the money from somewhere
and it's not the 170k a year they're
getting from us
so why are they
multi-multi-multi-multi-multi-millionaires
and why aren't we mad like why aren't we
throwing chairs we should be throwing
chairs we should have a national
throwing chairs day and just start
throwing chairs because at this point
it's insane that nobody's mad why am i
the only one mad at this
i think a lot of people are just either
not paying attention or
they just think they're going to comply
their way out of this well a lot of
people believe the other side is is so
much worse you know
picking between the lesser of two evils
people have been convinced that their
side is better when in reality they're
looking at absolute crap either way of
the spectrum but look look i see it all
the time on twitter where these
democrats are like republicans did this
or that in 2008 and i'm like you really
think republicans today have anything in
common with republicans back then i mean
there's people like mitch mcconnell for
sure but everybody hates him you know so
i i think the problem is people who
don't read and people who do i should
say the tribes are you've got the
uninitiated people who live in in wall-e
world on cnn and the people who actually
challenge the narrative and are reading
and trying to figure out what's really
going on thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you